you know I often have people say Dave
should you know you know I don't want to
beat that freer I'm not gonna marry him
I think that's dumb I think the guys
doing the right thing I think you marry
someone based on their the trajectory of
their life not based on where they are
today now if you call it you know let's
say they were debt free but they fully
intended to go borrow money on a car
tomorrow
and they were planned to keep a car
payment the rest of their life that's a
disqualifier for me because that's
stupid
but let's say they got $300,000 in debt
and they're willing to learn and they're
willing to sacrifice to get out of the
debt and willing to pay a price that's
marriage material that's good stuff
cuz you're going to be on the same page
the big deal is being on the same page
the number one cause of divorce in North
America today is not that it's arguments
over the money and the money problems
that debt brings and what we're gonna do
to get out of the debt or not do to get
out of the debt that's the number one
cause of marriage strife thus leading to
divorce in America today so that that's
what you want to do that's how you want
to look at this and so no I I don't tell
people to not marry someone because they
have debt and I didn't tell him that and
I don't believe he should cancel the
marriage I think he's on track I think
they're doing the right kinds of things
there but you know if somebody's just
like well I'm a princess and I'm always
going to borrow money or I'm little lord
fauntleroy and I'm always going to
borrow money why because the world runs
around me the axis of the world see that
thing sticking in the top of my head
that's the axis of the world everything
revolves around me I do whatever I want
whenever I want because they work so
hard
run don't marry that guy he's a wuss
he's a self-indulgent narcissist wuss
and you're gonna be in debt the rest of
your life buying crap to try to make
this [ __ ] happy run don't marry that
guy he's not marriage material or if you
reverse it that's the lady that's acting
that way then she's not a lady run this
is a princess and high-maintenance crazy
chick speaking of which one way you know
they're crazy is if they say they're not
I'm not crazy it's a pure
indication she's crazy run that'll help
you with that just for you younger guys
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below